anyway
thank you adfast for so many bits i made
three practical under promotions in the
last week that weren't the album track
oh
oh the album trap yeah so
going back to game two one of the main
traps in the albin like if we've just
followed
let's follow the leachat's database um
because most players take on e5 d4
and then over 21 000 players have played
e3 here
beginning to fall into the main trap e3
looks like a natural move
to challenge the pawn try and trade
queens
but after e3 there's bishop b4 check
and now we just follow the most common
moves bishop d2 takes
oh more people take okay um
but over 5200 people take on b4
as far as i know this is uh like the
quickest
under promotion opening trap
because after king e2 on move seven
we take on g1 and under promote to a
knight and this is the best move
important to deliver a check fourteen of
those people are against me add fast
eight
oh really oh wow oh so advanced eight is
a pro in this line
or just a true veteran
yeah this is a great great opening trap
and just to point out if we take with
queen this is not as strong
because we give white the opportunity to
trade queens
and
[Music]
that's actually equal material here but
when we take with knight
then we just wing white's queen
actually there's king e1 though key one
i assume black's just crushing but oh
queen h4 queen h4 g3 queen e4
okay looks fun who do i think will win
the speedchest championship
uh magnus or hikaru
or wesley probably not wesley
yeah magnus or hikaru i'm i'm pretty
sure we're going to see a
magnet so carto final
it'll be disappointing if we don't
anyway um i have 95 pending challenges
time to play a random sub
oh why would it be disappointing as far
as i know magnus and hikaru haven't
played
at least on just.com for years
okay i'm trying to mix up the openings
let's play um
playing zack zack zack no
no ratings so i'm gonna play
uh what do we call this hyper modern
or just a modern
you're great eric oh thank you
pallado hd
you're great too
um hear this move
i don't really know so much theory here
but i do know ideas
of developing pressuring the center
yeah mainly trying to pressure this pawn
like when you employ the setup there's a
bunch of ways to
uh to target d4 and not a gm yet
so much chess no nightbot can answer
that for you
yeah you can i guess you can be
knowledgeable about chess but
lack the gm title um
it comes down to like playing in in high
level events
and chasing norms and being
consistent enough to maintain a high
rating
uh play this move
and there's ideas of like e5 and c5
i think i want to take here
because otherwise if i play this this is
also maybe playable
[Music]
but let's keep things simple
okay
oh do i play e5
i think i do actually
my pawns are now smiling i'm okay with
on passant
and otherwise i'll develop
yeah 97 castle f5 ideas
it's not about opening to get a dynamic
position
and thank you chunko to thrash
412 and solving with prime
okay here i have a decision to make
like which pawn to take with
i think i wanna i wanna have three
center pawns
even though my bishop's very blocked in
there's cases where i castle
f5 okay that doesn't scare me
and my bishop can find a new home on c1
you don't even know me but you have been
teaching me how to play chess
that's amazing thanks
oh thank you petite
rocker
thanks for subbing i'm glad i can teach
you something
uh let's play a6
yeah so my two main pawn breaks here are
f5 and b5
i got the c file
actually if the c file opens it'll be
nice to
have my bishop to prevent white from
playing rook c1
nice positional idea
there's queen a5 hey eric hey
how's it going sisyphus
fafria thanks for subbing
okay let's keep playing positionally
maybe f5 will come very soon
oh man that prevents bishop h6 and
queen a5 like two moves i kind of wanted
to play
but it doesn't really prevent oh if i
play f5 i lose a pawn
let's play this move so reinforcing the
b-pawn
[Music]
maybe in some cases there's ideas of
playing d3
i have really enjoyed your videos from
the st louis
chess club oh that's great to hear
thanks for that hansen614
yeah that was kind of my i want to say
my birthplace
but it was my debut to like chess
educational content on youtube
what to play
maybe this move it's annoying i can't
play this
directly but h5 it's the beginning of
trying to make this move happen so my
plan is just this and this
tanner's back hey it's tanner the
mysterious
and majestic tanner thank you richard
mander
welcome back i really enjoy the youtube
uploads
keep them
did it mispronounce uploads
wait what
i really enjoy the youtube upload modes
keep them coming
i'm so confused because you spelled
uploads correctly
but the pronounced uploads like upload
modes
hey we need 98 more followers
if you're new here and you're you're not
following the channel
click follow it helps
the road to 70 000.
uh what to play it's actually a good
move
i might be losing a pawn
i mean not that i really oh there's no
increment there's no increment
um
[Music]
i'm probably okay with gamuting f5 is
kind of interesting
should probably play b4 though
i don't want to play b4
yeah let's play b4 i'm allowing this
kind of really oh
white doesn't do it okay now this is
really nice now
knight c4 was probably much better
i mean obviously white wanted to attack
this thing
but rook c3 just is such a nice square
and now now if white plays f4 i have d3
attacking everything
spot i've decided that uploads shall be
pronounced as
uploads wait now it now i pronounced it
correctly
i'm so confused yet again
knight d3 coming maybe play f6
preventing knight g5
my time i have to move a lot quicker so
there's no rook c1 because then i just
win everything
that should be a pretty easy position to
play
in time trouble
and queen is not having too many squares
play f5 it wasn't necessary
but oh oh am i gonna get a center pawn
cube
i might my g5 takes takes takes
my opponent better not flag i just want
a center pawn cube
i haven't had it since the jalalabad
opening
oh taki's still here in the form of
emote
and he occasionally stops by i know he's
been working a lot
i just want a pawn cube
oh this pond is joining the party
now i can't play this move i could but
it's not responsible
play this move first okay center pawn
cube
it's like that constellation right
my partner and i love good content three
oh i love you too
all my time oh but my opponent's time
climbing tree hard four house oh yeah
it's
life is all about climbing trees and
making a house
thanks brayden becoming a baby
what a game look at this it's like a
it's kind of like a c
what was it constellation
[Music]
someone help me the big dipper yeah big
dipper
images look at this
look at this big dipper
but it's kind of like a flipped big
dipper but that's okay
it's so beautiful because when you have
when you have a center pawn cube
it's hard to actually have pawns on
neighboring files
because it was necessary to have
captures but somehow i had
i had another capture
that was nice thanks for the game zack
zack zack
59 uh
put this into the the study
yeah opponent definitely played uh
a higher level than expected um
it's always kind of a a question
when the opponent doesn't have any any
like established rating
i i guess probably like somewhere in the
2000s
and i think this was a key moment
um even maybe earlier
yeah b5 may have been a little bit
premature
i should have probably just thrown this
move in preventing queen d2
preventing rook c1 and b5 would come
eventually
along with f5
but that was fun uh thanks for the game
if it goes on youtube hello to youtube
not every day i get a a pawn big dipper
this may have been my first ever pond
big dipper
it's going to be fun to design this
thumbnail